Довіра, близькість, професійна допомога -
ось що потрібно Шарлотті Поппе.
Жінці 84 роки -
вона вела повноцінне життя аж до глибокої старості.
Однак останні сім років уже не може впоратися
без сторонньої допомоги.
Я не можу зробити собі каву,
не можу навіть налити гарячу воду в чашку,
бо обпікаюсь.
І я не можу вже приготувати собі їжу.
Після операції  жінка впала у кому,
тепер вона поступово відновлюється,
але їй потрібен постійний догляд.
Удома її доглядає донька,
однак коли у неї немає такої можливості,
за старенькою доглядають у спеціальному притулку.
Я почуваюся тут дуже добре.
Вони дуже добре піклуються про пацієнтів.
Якщо я дзвоню, тоді одразу хтось з'являється.
Треба натиснути кнопку, і хтось прийде.
Все робиться так, як мені того й хотілося б.
Оцей заклад у Гамбурзі - один найбільших будинків догляду
а людьми похилого віку в Німеччині.
Тут 1100 мешканців і 900 працівників.
Обслуговує лікарню католицька благодійна організація.
У цьому відділенні так званого короткострокового догляду
4 медсестер обслуговують 38 пацієнтів.
Якщо якась із медсестер раптом захворіє, своєчасно знайдуть заміну.
Тобто якісний догляд гарантовано.
Це розкіш порівняно з іншими такими закладами.
Доглядальниця Ванесса Ахікех охоче тут працює.
Для неї догляд за літніми людьми більше, ніж просто робота.
Ідеться насамперед про самих людей,
про потреби хворих, про повагу до літніх людей,
про досвід спілкування з людьми похилого віку.
Можна багато чому навчитися одне від одного,
це те, що мені дуже подобається.
І також бути тією людиною, якій вони довіряють.
Це добре, коли медсестри так виконують свою роботу.
Однак на Інтернет-форумах можна знайти багато відгуків людей, що потребують догляду,
які мали цілком протилежний досвід з доглядальницями.
Ринок надання послуг із догляду змінюється,
ціни підвищуються. Дедалі більше приватних компаній
заходять на цей ринок і купують будинки догляду за літніми людьми,
які раніше функціонували на гроші громади.
Дохід від такої діяльності забезпечений,
адже попит на догляд для літніх людей у Німеччині дуже високий.
Економлять компанії передусім на персоналі.
У багатьох будинках з догляду за людьми похилого віку гостра нестача медсестер.
Справді важко знайти людей.
Це наша найбільше проблема.
Отримати висококваліфікованих працівників дійсно нереально проблематично.
Однак працювати у сфері догляду не хочуть через погану оплату праці.
Приватні будинки догляду економлять на чому тільки можна.
Іноді працівникам виплачують лише половину
передбаченої тарифною угодою зарплатні.
І це - за важку фізичну працю з позмінною роботою
і готовністю працювати цілодобово.
Якщо все залишити, як є,
проблема нестачі кваліфікованих доглядальниць у Німеччині
лише зашгострюватиметься. Адже тривалість життя німців зростає.
У майбутньому буде ще більше людей,
які потребують догляду.
За статистикою, до 2030 року
таких людей буде три з половиною мільйони.